hey what's up guys I'm Fadi and I'm Hal
Kate Drake and today we are going to
show you five things you definitely
didn't know about Dark Souls so usually
with this series I say that if you learn
something new then you should leave a
like but honestly you guys aren't gonna
get any of these how kite is amazing at
digging around in the games file so
these are things the average person just
wouldn't know no it's not that I'm
doubting you it's just don't get too
upset if you don't get many ok you'll
see what I mean if you still want to
play the game with a like system then
how about if you learn 5 new things then
you leave a like and if you know
anything on the list then feel free to
leave a dislike guilt free anyway all
five of these things are awesome so
let's get started but what should we
start off with man I think we should
start off with undead kings Ariel number
one there's a cut or scrapped boss named
undead king Jarriel undead kings Ariel
seems to be a boss who is cut from
development his name indicates that he
is either a king of the undead or a king
who is undead I believe it's more likely
that he was a king over New Londo which
according to the crestfallen warrior it
was one to an undead City the cut
dialogue from Ingrid indicates Cesario
may have been fought atop the church
roof or Ingrid ended up standing he's
referred to as a dark wraith which we
know to be true since he fights with a
dark hand a tool of the darkwraiths it's
likely that he was the one that Ingrid
is referring to
Dario wields a dark hand that he can use
his shield punch and maybe even drain
humanity with there's actually a level
draining effect still left in the game
that will flash with red text similar to
the text that appears when equipment
breaks or when you're cursed he also has
the same sound bites as king of land
from demon souls who was able to drain
soul levels
not to mention Jerry land the four kings
share the same AI script indicating that
he may have been scrapped in favor of
the four kings or may have had a script
repurposed for the boss fight the four
kings seem to wear a corrupted version
of his armor with a crescent spike
coming out from his shoulder and pieces
that move outwards from the middle the
four kings were once rulers of humanity
corrupted by the dark and there are many
conclusions to be drawn from the
similarities between the to defeat
undead kings Ariel and you'll get the
key to the seal from Ingrid along with
his brilliant armor
number two
as you can see Frampton karthe have more
animations than are currently in the
game by replacing the model of frampt or
cath over the AI of characters with
attack or death animations you can see
these terrifying and often hilarious
animations obviously when they created
frames and cars they were meant to be
killable enemies but man I'm kind of
glad you can't kill them I prefer to
think of them as these mysterious and
mortal beings even though they're
already this goofy looking snake with a
moustache and if this head smash
animation was in the game it might have
shattered that already fragile image and
speaking of attack animations number
three the living trees in the darker
garden have attack animations they can
swipe down at you with their vines this
was probably left on youth so that the
trees could trick players into thinking
that the path is blocked by a real tree
number four and five both have to do
with Priscilla did you know that
Priscilla has unique sitting and
standing animations according to the
Dark Souls design works interviews
Priscilla was originally going to be a
sort of heroine character Miyazaki later
elaborated saying that her role was
replaced by the fire keepers a variety
of sitting poses are reminiscent of the
maiden in black from Demon Souls it was
always sitting in a different way in the
Nexus did you also know that every enemy
in the burg was originally meant to be
Priscilla I'm just kidding just kidding
and for the final thing this is your
last chance to redeem yourself if you
haven't known anything so far so again
according to the design works interviews
the painted world was originally a
prototype map one of the first the
developer worked on personally I think
this is why it's such a well designed
level there's absolutely no signs that
they rushed it there's a variety of
enemies to fight the level has great
pacing it loops around brilliantly and
there's a lot of different situations
you can get yourself into anyway back on
topic
the final thing you didn't know so in
Priscilla's boss room there's actually a
3d mesh for a breaking floor which is
similar to the breaking floor where you
fight the stray demon in the asylum not
only this but we know that NATO was
originally placed in the game's
prototype map which as I've said before
is the painted world of ariamis so we
can only assume that NATO was originally
placed below this breaking floor there
are even spiraling stairs that lead back
up from the fall right below
if you look at a map viewer so this was
obviously an earlier version of NATO
before he found a more appropriate home
in the catacombs you know where he could
wear a different skeleton for every day
of the week and that's it if you were
playing a game with the like system then
leave a like if you learned five new
things today and that's not all if
you're hungry for more cutthroat
Hellkite Drake's channel his will be the
first link in the description he has an
entire series devoted to cut content so
if you're looking for more that's the
place to be not only that but he also
makes great remixes of the game
soundtrack so go check it out and if
you're looking for more things you
didn't know about Dark Souls then click
the playlist link on the screen choose
guys I'll see you in the next one
welcome everybody to the next episode of
Souls news it's actually been a little
while since I made one of these and
that's partly because all of the big
news right now deserves its own video
all of which are the most recent videos
on my channel so if you haven't seen
those then check them out they're there
if you didn't watch them but for now
let's open with a discussion